Do bed bugs sleep?
Because if they do I say it’s high time
we bite them back!
Hey there sleeping pill bugs, Julian here
for DNews.
We’re still not exactly sure why we need
to sleep but almost every animal does it.
Humans, cats, dogs, cats, birds, cats, even
fish and cats!
So just how deep does the rabbit hole go?
Do insects, for instance, need a little shut
compound-eye?
It’s not an easy question to answer because
it’s not like bugs have eyelids they can
actually close and we still haven’t devised
tiny brain wave scanners that can detect a
resting pattern.
So scientists had to define what insect sleep
looks like, and in 2000 they did just that.
Two separate groups from the Neuroscience
Institute of California and the University
of Pennsylvania studied fruit flies to see
if they behaved similarly to us.
The researchers found that at night, they
were immobile and had a higher arousal threshold,
meaning it took more than usual to startle
them and get them moving5.
The scientists also found that if they deprived
the flies of sleep at night by continually
tapping the container they were in, the flies
would rest during the day, exhibiting “sleep
rebound.”
If you’ve ever worked all night and then
slept like a log in a coma the whole day,
you can relate to the flies.
And if you used caffeine to pull an all nighter,
the flies can relate to you: turns out the
chemical that keeps us buzzing does the same
for fruit flies.4
Since the first observations of fruit fly
sleep in 2000 more insects have been caught
napping.
The males of some species of bees that don’t
live in hives sleep by locking their jaws
onto a flower and relaxing the rest of their
body.
They exhibit the same change in arousal threshold:
as you can see in this video, when this sleeping
bee is poked, it lazily waves a leg like it’s
asking for 5 more minutes.
And if bees are kept awake, they show the
same negative side effects we do.
Biologist Barrett Klein studies the sleep
of bees and invented a device called the Insominator,
which is officially the best name for anything
ever.
Klein would tag some bees with steel and some
with copper.
The Insominator would keep the steel-clad
bees awake by jarring them with magnets.
Meanwhile, bees tagged with non-magnetic copper
would be unaffected.
The next day when the steel-clad sleepy bees
had to communicate where flowers were by doing
the waggle dance -- yes that’s the official
name -- they weren’t as accurate as their
well rested brethren.
Sleep deprivation makes bees a little muddled,
just like us.
And if it goes on for too long, it can have
worse consequences.
A study that kept fruit flies awake for an
extended period saw a third of them die.
So extreme sleep deprivation can be fatal
for insects, just like us.
Some researchers think if it doesn’t outright
kill them, it can shorten a bug’s life span.
A University of South Florida study of fire
ants found that queens get much more rest
than the workers.
The queens would regularly doze off 90 times
a day for 6 minutes at a time, which adds
up to 9 hours.
Workers on the other hand took minute long
power naps at random, 250 times a day.
That adds up to less than 5 hours.
Incidentally, workers only live up to a year,
while queens can live for up to 6 years.
The worker ants sleeping pattern means that
80% of the colony is awake at any given time
so they can continuously get stuff done.13
Other insects sleep when there’s not much
point in being awake: flowers close up at
night, so honeybees can catch some zzzzs.
Humans aren’t on mattresses during the day
so bed bugs sleep then.
The New Zealand weta lives at an altitude
where it freezes overnight so it might as
well go into cryosleep.
And spiders…
Spiders aren’t insects, they never sleep.
They’re always watching.
Kidding… probably.
If you’re a tired bee, maybe your mattress
is your own insominator.
Eve Mattress has spent 4 years perfecting
the memory foam mattress, and they sell it
direct to you online at a third the price
of traditional stores.
And since you watch DNews you can save even
more.
Go to www.evemattress.com now for your exclusive
offer - enter promo code dnews125 to get $125
off today
Hey remember how I mentioned fish sleep and
you were really curious as to how that’s
even possible?
Well Trace and Dr. Kiki Sanford tell you all
about it here.
Before we brought it up I bet you never wondered
if insects sleep, but these are the questions
that keep us up at night.
If you have your own you’d like us to answer,
ask us!